and youth talk before you've done your
own classes what's one of the most
common questions then you've been asked
by someone is how to work with actors oh
okay that's the one everyone wants to
know
give us the hardest thing to do how to
work with an actor it's uh and it's
funny to me that that's the hardest
question and you know it's weird is
actors will often ask me actually actors
will often thank me for directing them
because they say most people don't which
is an interesting thing but yeah how do
you work with an actor how do you get
them to do what you want them to do and
I hear here's my I have a theory on that
do you have a theory on all these things
but directors are mechanical people by
nature and they're multitaskers this is
a good thing you kind of need to be
because when you're on set you're being
asked 400 questions simultaneously all
the time you only have to write shirt or
the blue shirt if you want the you know
what lens are we on 25 35 you thinking
longer you know or dolly Steadicam what
color do you like do you like this color
on the wall is it you know what it you
know is this the scene where Bob shows
up or Jill shows up you know it's just
these you're constantly shuffling and
juggling and I'm just trying to go to
the bathroom
this is that's the nature of filmmaking
and it's fun that energy is really fun
the actor will come on and go how do I
be deeper that's a different question
because every other question you dealt
with on set is a mechanical one a binary
one you know it's red or blue it's is
this a 25 mil ends or you know hundred
no you know why you can click a box or
flip a switch and it gives you your
answer actor is not that way they they
are a person they're an emotion and I
think the scare is a lot of directors
it's just why they hide in video village
and shout their direction to the actor
onset way over there directing actors
especially when you're new at it I'm
often reminded of the very first time I
held a baby because it doesn't talk it
just Wiggles
and sometimes it's Julie and dude you're
like um I I don't know what to do with
this thing like that's how it can feel
it's scary and this is where you get the
classic direction the the classic
direction for directors don't know what
they're doing is take it up a notch
there is no more mechanical
words than that phrase take it up a
notch here let me take your emotional
dial and that's where that comes from
can you be more angrier can you be
sadder you know they want to dial up and
down well you're dealing with a human
it's a relationship it's an intent they
now of course good actors can probably
interpret what you're saying but you
can't rely on that and that's this is
one thing that drives me crazy when I
hear people say well your key to good
directing is casting yeah it is but you
know if you're just gonna let your
actors do all the work without you
saying something to them they still want
to know your point to the scene or a
general direction because you're looking
at the entire 30,000 foot view of your
story they still want to know what you
want or if they're getting there for you
so you can't totally rely on then that's
also not realistic because every single
project it's drawn let's say you do your
indie film well you know how many times
it happens where the the the investor
says I'm gonna give you the money for
the film and but my daughter has always
wanted to be an actress right and she's
never acted before and suddenly you as
the director have to deal with that look
every single day for every job on the
set you know your DP your ad your your
production designer your more to a
person they're all experts in their
field and you could come on not knowing
anything about any of those departments
and be fine your DP will carry you
because they that's what they do the one
job that no one will carry you is
directing your actors you better know
how to talk to them and that's the one
thing that almost no one understands how
to do it's crazy to me this is why a lot
of people say
you should take an acting class and I
think that's not enough you should
regularly take one and even better if
you really want to learn teach one I did
this in my own personal journey I
started I just took four actors and I
said come to my studio I'm gonna give
you a scene from a play I'm just gonna
try to direct it and see without any
cameras or lights take that out of the
equation all I have in my words and let
me see if I can make you connect on a
deeper level that's terrifying
because what do you say if they're not
connecting to people talking and they're
not connecting there is no switch that
will make that happen it comes to a
relationship and I had an actor friend
tell me one time that an actor's
performance is a reflection of the
director if they are not opening up it's
probably because you're not opening up
if they are not feeling as deeply as you
want them to feel then that probably
means that you're not feeling as deeply
as you like I've had this happen on set
where it's like I in fact that when I
was experimenting with working with
actors I had a actress come to me and
she says I'm and I was telling her like
you're not opening up to your scene
partner your need to open up I'm a
mechanic still trying to turn the knob
open open
it's not working she was frustrated she
said yeah I get this note all the time
and I don't know what the problem is and
so that's where I got this advice maybe
it's a reflection of the director so I
said okay well you know that's
interesting about that is because she is
not someone I personally care for you
know I she's a nice person but I didn't
really connect to her so I was resisting
getting to know her or opening up
personally to her now I'm not telling
her this I'm just being honest so the
next time she showed up I made a point
to ask her about her kids to get to know
her a little bit just to like maybe I
can find a way for me to personally as a
director connect to who she is and she
bloomed emotional talking about this but
it's so vital because that's what you
need you need them to open up to be
there because that's what the cameras
you want them to see that look in their
eyes that gets them to be there and it
requires you as a director to be open as
well hmm again emotion about this stuff
because because I think it's important I
think video village becomes the shelter
to shout your directions at because
they're doing something you're terrified
to do actors are doing the thing that is
done that is unnatural for the rest of
us to be naked in front of the world not
just physically sometimes but
emotionally to really those actors that
you're drawn to are the ones that are
just so raw Joaquin Phoenix being one
like you just you can't take your eyes
off him because it's just so out there
that's what you need that requires you
as the director to be there right there
with them so when it comes to directing
actors that's where you begin in
suppression in the movie I just did we
had a scene where towards the end of the
film the actor really it was the
climactic emotional climax of the film
and he really had to just fall apart of
this break open and I was scared I was
terrified of this scene I was terrified
from day one that the scene was coming I
hadn't worked with his actor before and
he was I knew he was scared it was his
first leading role on a movie and we we
both had mentioned the scene all the way
up and I purposely wasn't saying
anything about it because I didn't want
him to know I was scared but I could
tell that he was so we get to the day
and using all those things I've been
telling you well I started the day by
just telling him about some of my
biggest mistakes and some of my own
personal struggles and and this the
scene was about him opening up about his
father and so I just started telling him
stories about my life and asking him
questions about his and things he'd been
through it just really as a human off
set while they're lighting and stuff
just as human just talking just opening
up he's getting emotional it's like you
know connecting person to person so then
when it came time to do the scene excuse
me we put the camera it was a very you
know intimate shot it got up to close
and I you know I hate video village
personally I like to have an L monitor
and I want to sit right there with the
actors so that we're very close if it's
emotionally powerful scene it's
important I think to be physically close
so they're not yelling anything you just
right there with them I got there with
them we were old camera and I just told
him okay I'm not gonna say action all
I'm gonna say is you don't have to hold
on to this anymore
but my hand on his back and he just
brewed we just blew up in the seemed
like it was amazing and it was sat there
right there with it physically until he
just did it was he was a beautiful
performance he's beautiful but it
required enormous amounts of Terror for
me to open up to allow that to happen
and this also requires a lot of
emotional maturity because I have to be
able to in this state of if they're safe
they're you know I keep saying deep
emotion and crying and stuff I have to
be able to be emotional with them but
turn right around to the DP and say so
when we do this make sure you push while
I am emotional you know it's hard to do
to be like that but that's what we're
asking actors to do that's really what
their job is and once you start to
understand that and be comfortable with
that kind of emotion then you can start
to learn how to talk to them about
different emotions so classic direction
things are you know the result direction
you hear that be angrier that's that's a
result direction I you know if you read
a judith Olsen this book I believe it's
called directing actors it's a really
good book she there's a method in the
book she talks about using words like
punish them or threaten or tease I'm
gonna go to the store okay I want you to
say that line but threaten me with that
you know that that that that's great
actors love that stuff sometimes I like
to if they're not say getting angry or
if I know that's what I need them to be
is more angry and more dug in
this is the last thing you can say to
them ever this is the end of the
conversation now come at it that way
sometimes they'll even go okay that was
amazing but we can go deeper let's dig a
little bit deeper these that's not
result directing that's a relational
thing sometimes they'll have their scene
partner tell them something that I may
trigger them now I'll say this but this
is you have to really be careful with
that because it's not a trick it's not
being mean to the actor it's not abusing
them which we've heard stories yes
that's it that's I cannot tell you
that's not acting I've heard store or er
stories of people saying like say racial
insults to someone to get them to be
angry that's that's not directing that's
just being a jerk and that's not you do
that you're gonna ruin the trust of your
actor and they'll shut down for you then
won't come back
it pisses me off because it's not it's
mean it's unfair they're trying to open
up and be an emotional and you're just
abusing them that's what you're doing
that's and you're gonna get a reputation
for being that way so but what I mean is
like you know all right you know I'm a
whisper to the actor God done this
before we'll see ask them a question
that's not in the script in character
okay okay it's an action so what is your
favorite color anyway it's great because
you'll get what you'll get is just the
actor tentacley being this works great
with kids too by the way to get them if
they're struggling with line readings
and they're reading it the same way that
happens a lot where they'll learn it
with their parents a certain way but
they're having a hard time breaking that
pattern you can get the other actor if
they're an adult especially to like play
with them a little bit get them to ask
other questions these are ways you can
get what you want your goal is to get it
to be real we want truth in the scene
that's the goal always no matter what
genre you're working with so doing
things like that is really helpful
sometimes and it's important also to pay
attention to the physical things that
they like some actors are physical make
them clench their fists make them ball
up some actors really respond to that
having them savings is another way
before the take starts you know I have
them apologized in there seeing partner
I'm sorry I'm sorry and then okay now
action you know being emotionally
available and in in tune also comes to
play and when you see them resisting you
understanding that understand all
they're scared they're worried about
this seem not looking good okay they're
worried about being humiliated because
of what they're doing okay okay we can
deal with that that means as a director
I need to assure you that I got your
back I'm not gonna let you fail you know
that comes from just being very
emotionally intelligent you know that
takes study you can't just take an
acting class and learn that you need to
read books need that I mean go to
therapy go to read therapy books about
human behavior open yourself up
understand how your own mind works
understand your own insecurities and the
way you function that's how you get to
the root because you know what that's
what actors are doing in their classes
most of those acting classes are like
therapy sessions they're unlearning
human defenses right and figuring out
ways around them and the better you get
at that the better you're gonna start
spotting things like say for example
there are some people who freak out and
they're acting like they're they're like
the the violin guy I'm seeing this for
this like they're great at throwing a
temper tantrum but if you're if you
study it long enough you'll start to
recognize oh that's not acting that's a
show they're doing that because it looks
sexy but it's not they're not feeling
anything they're they're hiding they're
using that as a smokescreen so only by
study meticulous study and practices
you'll start to recognize those things
so it's and it's that's that's wrecking
that's what that's if you study nothing
else that's the skills you learn because
there's no trust in that I've taken
acting classes like that and where
people would just be devastated and
they'd be crying because one person was
coming on to one person and they really
liked them and the other person was
totally tearing them down and it was
just like this devastating thing to
watch
and it was like I don't want to sign up
for this yeah that's happens a lot yeah
mm-hmm you know and if you've seen that
happen on set to you as a director it's
your job to protect them you know yeah
yeah it can happen really that's it
you know you as a director you you are a
protector in a way of sometimes from a
scene partner sometimes let's say it's a
nude scene understanding that that's
humiliating and maybe you don't need to
have all these people in the room or
it's an emotional scene and they're
trying to open up and having a hard time
because there's too many people in the
room if someone's making jokes over here
like protecting him in that way
sometimes protecting them from
themselves is important like like I've
had to tell actors look we're really
wide on this shot
so I'm not reading all the emotion on
your face say don't don't throw it all
out there just yet just hold on to some
of that like make your movements bigger
in this tape but then we're gonna come
in for a close-up next time so just you
know cuz that can happen too they can
they could blow themselves out and we
don't even see them in the shot you know
you're that that comes down to having
their back I'll tell you the the best
thing the way I've gotten the best
performance is about from an actor and
this is so much fun is if you can you
shoot your scene you get it all done and
you saw a little bit of time and you
tell the actor all right we've got it in
the can it's all there this one's for
you you cannot make a mistake you cannot
fail
no now try one just try stuff they get
every time I've done that almost every
time that's the take I use because
they're now they're operating without a
net they know they can't fail but if you
do this important if you do that if you
tell them that don't direct them let
them do it don't judge what they say
don't try to curb it again just let them
let them do it if it works it works if
it not no big deal we've already got it
you know and then don't do 50 more takes
like let that be the last one and then
move forward so yeah and that's when you
get surprised and that is the joy of
filming
right there when you are surprised by
the what the other artists are bringing
to the table that goes for all the
departments by the way you know being
surprised by what the D P's idea was and
you're like oh man I never realized
that's how cool it could guess the fun
part of filmmaking that's what we all
want it's and it's when the actors do it
it's nothing better nothing better
you
because you don't want to push you know
tear them apart sure that's hard man
it's hard to do that could work what
they're doing is yeah you know you're at
rest your crew is more physical they're
not
I remember tried crying for 12 straight
hours that's hard to do or laughing for
straight you know or physical comedy or
whatever